ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERONE
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL. AGUIAR-CURRY
ARAMBULA. OUR QUE HAN BENNETT
BERMAN BIGELOW BLOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA BURKE
CALDERON CARRILLO CERVANTES
CHAU CHEN CHIU CHOI COOLEY
COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALY DALY
DAVIES FLORA FONG. FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KILEY LACKEY LIII LEVINE LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN NGUYEN
O'DONNELL. ANDERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
AHMOSE RAY IS THREE OF US
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO SAY ARTURO SMITH
STONE THING WHILE OTHERS VIA
FOOD WA VOEPEL WALDRON BOARD
WICKS WORD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS. A QUORUM IS PRESENT WE
ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN
THE REAR F THE CHAMBER AND IN
THE GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR
THE PRAYER. THE DAYS PRAYER
WILL BE OFFERED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK SILVA
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PHILIP. LET US
PRAY. HEAVENLY FATHER TODAY WE
CELEBRATE TALENTED WOMEN WHO
HAVE MADE A DIFFERENCE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THIS IS NOT
ACCIDENTAL YOUR GUIDANCE AND
LYFT HAVE GIVEN THESE WOMEN
STRAIGHT. COURAGE AND
INSPIRATION LORD YOU ARE ALWAYS
LEADING US TO THE LIGHT DURING
THE DAYS OF SLAVERY WE KNOW
THAT YOU'VE GUIDED HERRIOT
TOBIN AND THOUGH SHE LED TO
SAFETY AND FREEDOM. LORD AT THE
END FRANK HID IN AN ATTIC
DURING HORRIFIC TIME. WE KNOW
THAT IT WAS YOU THE PUT A PEN
AND PAPER IN HER HAND AND THE
WILL TO WRITE HER STORY. AS A
CALIFORNIA FARM WORKERS BEG FOR
SAFE WORKING CONDITIONS AND
ADVOCACY IT WOULD YOU LORD.
THEY GAVE THAT FIGHTING VOICE
AND ADVOCATES ADVOCACY ROLE TO
DOLORES HUERTA. LORD AS TINY
RUTH PATER GINSBURG STOOD JUST
FIVE FEET TALL WE KNOW IT WAS
YOU THAT LED HER TO LEAD LIKE A
GIANT WITH THE GAVEL WINNER
HAND. AND JUST THIS WEEKEND
LORD WE KNOW THAT YOU STOOD BY
WORLD CHAMPION SNOWBOARDER
CHOLE CHLOE KIM. TO A NEW WORLD
CHAMPION SHIP TITLE FOR
PERFORMING A HALF PIPE.
MANEUVER SAFELY TODAY LORD I
ASK YOU TO CRADLE OUR CHILDREN
IN YOUR LOVE. AND TO GIVE HOPE
TO MOMS WHO RAISE CHILDREN
ALONE AND TO COMFORT THE
MOTHERS WHO HAVE LOST A CHILD.
I ASK THAT YOU HELP HEAL OUR
NATION. AND HELP GUIDE US BACK
TO HAVING FAITH IN ONE ANOTHER.
AND HELP US LEAD WITH
COMPASSION DIGNITY AND COURAGE
OUR MEN. THANK YOU MISS CLARK
SILVA WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING AND
JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY ISSUE LEADS US IN
THE PLEDGE IN THE REAR. CHAMBER
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG. OF THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA. AND TO THE REPUBLIC
FOR WHICH IT STANDS. ONE NATION
UNDER GOD. INDIVISIBLE WITH
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
LIVING TO THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL.
SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY MARCH
TENTH ONE IN THIS WALDRON
SECONDS FOR THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH. PRESENTATION OF
PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
ARE NONE. HAVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS TODAY'S ABSENCES
FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHANDAN FOR THE ILLNESS IN THE
FAMILY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN.
THIS RACE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
YOUR MOTION. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE ONE ONE EIGHT EIGHT TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER. CRISTINA
GARCIA TO HELP PHOTOGRAPHERS ON
THE FLOOR WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER. I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG TO SPEAK
ON IN THE GERMAN AND MEMORY
TODAY WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX AND
SIXTY THREE TO WITHDRAW SB
NINETY FIVE SKINNER. FROM THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE AND ORDER THE
BILL TO THIRD READING TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAM TO TAKE UP
THE MEASURE TODAY WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE. MISTER
KALRA. WE WITHHOLDING INSTANCE
ENOUGH ROLL CALL VOTE HEY
MITHRAS MOVES AND MISS WALDRON
SECONDS. THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHERE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. THIS
RACE IS ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE
MISTER FLORA IS ASKING FOR A NO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE MISS REYES IS ASKING FOR
AN AYE VOTE MISTER FLORA IS
ASKING FOR A NO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THIRTY DESERVE A. WELL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY THOSE
EYES FORTY EIGHT KNOWS THIRTEEN
THE MOTION CARRIES.
MEMBERS.
MEMBERS. WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
FILE ITEM ONE HR TWENTY SIX THE
CLERK WILL READ CONSULAR
SOLUTION TWENTY SIX BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA RELATIVE
TO WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH. MISS
GARCIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THE RESOLUTION. THANK YOU
MEMBERS MADAM SPEAKER AS THE
CHAIR THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS. I
READ THROUGH THE 2% HOUSE
RESOLUTION TWENTY SIX
PROCLAIMING MARCH TWENTY FIRST
AS WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH.
DURING THIS MONTH TO PAY
TRIBUTE TO THE MANY AMAZING
WOMEN THAT HAVE COME BEFORE US.
AND A LARGE OUT THERE STILL
MUCH WORK TO BE DONE IN
CALIFORNIA ACROSS OUR COUNTRY.
AND EVEN IN OUR OWN STATE
LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE WE HAVE
PARTY AT ALL LEVELS OF SOCIETY.
TODAY WE CELEBRATE THE FACT
THAT A LITTLE OVER A HUNDRED
YEARS AGO WOMEN FOUGHT FOR THE
RIGHT TO VOTE. IN A RIGHT TO
SERVE IN OFFICE. BUT TODAY WE
MUST ALSO DOUBLE DOWN ON OUR
EFFORTS TO ENSURE OUR STATE
LEGISLATURE LOOKS MORE LIKE THE
GREAT STATE WE COLLECTIVELY
REPRESENT. A LITTLE OVER A
HUNDRED YEARS AGO THE FIRST
FOUR WOMAN. ELIZABETH HUGHES.
ANNA SAILOR AS THE BROUGHT TO
AN INJURY STORIES WERE ELECTED
INTO THE STATE ASSEMBLY. IT
TOOK ANOTHER HALF CENTURY AFTER
THAT SELECT THE FIRST BLACK
WOMAN IN THE FIRST APA WOMAN
INTO THE STATE ASSEMBLY YOU MOM
BURKE AND MARCH ON YOU. AND
MORE THAN A HALF A CENTURY
LATER MRS BURKE SOLDER SERVICE
US THIRD WITH US AS THE ONLY
BLACK WOMAN IN THE ASSEMBLY.
AND THERE'S ONLY ONE OTHER
BLACK WOMEN IN THE STATE SENATE.
AND OUR COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE
COUNTY IS THE ONLY A POOR WOMAN
IS THE LEGISLATURE. THIRTY NINE
YEARS AGO THE FIRST LATINA
GLORIA MOLINA WAS ELECTED TO
THE STATE ASSEMBLY SHE WAS ALSO
MY REPRESENTATIVE. AND DURING
MY TENURE IN THE STATE ASSEMBLY
THERE WAS A TIME WHEN THERE
WERE ONLY THREE LET THE MATH IN
THE STATE LEGISLATURE. EVEN
THOUGH WE COMPRISE 20% OF THE
POPULATION. BUT THERE IS GOOD
NEWS. WELL WE DON'T HAVE PARTY
YET WE DO HAVE A TEAM AT THE
NECESSARY IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE TODAY. A HUNDRED
YEARS SINCE THE FIRST WOMEN
WERE ELECTED TO THE STATE
LEGISLATURE AND OUR CURRENT
WOMAN CAUCUS MEMBERS CONTINUE
TO MAKE HISTORY AND BREAK LAST
MEANS. IN TWO THOUSAND AND TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM NORTH STATE WHEN IT BECAME
THE THIRTY EIGHTH WOMEN TO JOIN
OUR LEGISLATURE. DURING THE
200-019-2020 TERM THAT'S THE
MOST OF THEM NEVER HAD SERVING
AT ANY ONE TIME BUT STILL
TWENTY TWO SECOND PARTY. SO OUR
CURRENT MEMBERS HAVE BEEN THEIR
FIRST TOWN- FIRST FEMALE MAYORS.
SUMMARIZES UNDOCUMENTED
CHILDREN WHO FACE DEPORTATION
ONLY TO NOW SERVE IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE. SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES LEFT BEHIND
EVERYTHING AND EVERYONE THEY
LOVE FLEEING CIVIL WARS ON THE
TO DO THEY SERVE IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE. SOME OF OUR
COLLEAGUES ARE BROKEN RECORDS
RECEIVING THE HIGHEST AMOUNT OF
VOTES IN THE STATE'S HISTORY OF
THE LEGISLATIVE. IN LEGISLATIVE
RACES. OUR COLLEAGUES IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY ON THE RED
CARPET IS THE YOUNGEST WOMAN
EVER ELECTED. SERVING WITH US
THE FIRST EMAIL VETERAN EVER TO
SERVE IN THE STATE LEGISLATURE.
HERE IN OUR OWN HOUSE OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM GLENDALE LET
DURING THE ME TOO MOVEMENT AS
THE CHAIR OF THE JOINT RULES
COMMITTEE ON SEXUAL HARASSMENT
PREVENTION RESPONSE. SHE LETTER
STARK BICAMERAL AND BIPARTISAN
REFORM OF THE STATE
LEGISLATURE'S RESPONSE TO
SEXUAL HARASSMENT. THEY BECAME
A MODEL FOR OTHER STATES AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. CURRENTLY
SERVING WITH US FOR THE FIRST
MEDINA MAJORITY LEADER. THE
PRESS THAT THE NATURE OF
APPROPRIATIONS THE FIRST AND
ONLY LET THE UNITED STATES- IN
THE C. LETS THESE ARE FROM
ORANGE COUNTY. THE FIRST
REPUBLICAN AT THE NEST IN THE
STATE ASSEMBLY AND SENATE. THE
FIRST AT THE NATURE OF THE
SENATE INSURANCE COMMITTEE THE
FIRST LATINA AND WOMEN OF COLOR
TO CHAIR THE SENATE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE. THE
FIRST OPENLY LGBTQ I LET THE
MAN THE SENATE. BUT A HUNDRED
YEARS AFTER WE FIRST GOT THE
RIGHT TO VOTE AND GET ELECTED
WE ONLY HAVE ONE OPENLY LGBTQ I
WOMAN IN THE ASSEMBLY. SERVING
WITH US ON THE RED CARPET IS
THE HIGHEST RANKING AT THE END
THE STATE GOVERNMENT WHEN
APPOINTED AS SECRETARY OF
BUSINESS CONSUMER SERVICES. AND
HOUSING AGENCY OTHER- GOVERNOR
JERRY BROWN. BUT WE STILL HAVE
NOT HAD A SINGLE AT THE NO
SERVICE STATEWIDE OFFICE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN DIEGO HAS NOTED WITH
THEIR WORK ON ANYTHING THAT THE
MASS. THE LATINOS ARE OFTEN THE
MOST UNDERPAID AND HE'S
REPRESENTED IN MOST SECTORS OF
THE FIGHTING. AMONG SAYS WE
HAVE THE FREE SINGLE PRESIDENT
OF THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION. THE FIRST EMAIL
SECRETARY OR TREASURER SIX
SECRETARY TREASURER OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY FEDERATION OF
LABOR. AFL-CIO THE SECOND
LARGEST LABOR COUNCIL IN THE
COUNTRY ONE OF THE FIRST WOMEN
APPROVED TO FLY ABOARD AND EAT
PT RECONNAISSANCE AIRCRAFT
OVERSEAS. ONLY THE SECOND WOMAN
TO HEAD A PARTY CAUCUS IN THE
HISTORY OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE. AND THE FIRST WOMAN TO
LEAD BOTH HOUSES ARE SENATE PRO
TEM TONI ATKINS. I WOULDN'T
CAUCUS MEMBERS HAVE NOT ONLY
BEEN BREAKING GLASS CEILINGS
BUT ARE UNITED TO ENSURE THAT
ALL WOMEN HAVE A PATHWAY TO
OVERCOME THE TREMENDOUS
CHALLENGES. AND OBSTACLES THEY
FACED A CONTINUOUSLY FIGHTING
TO ENSURE ALL WOMEN BE TREATED
RESPECTED AND PAID RIGHTFULLY
WHAT WE DESERVE. AND THIS LED
TO THIS THIS SESSION WILL BE
ANY DIFFERENT. EXCEPT THAT THE
PANDEMIC HAS FURTHER
EXACERBATED AND HIGHLIGHTED THE
WORK WE NEED TO DO TO LIFT UP
ALL WOMEN. AND GIVEN US A
GREATER SENSE OF URGENCY. THE
COVER NINETEEN CRISIS AS BETTER
SECTORS IN WHICH WOMEN'S
EMPLOYMENT IS MORE
CONCENTRATED. THE SET THOSE UP
CLOSE ON DAYCARE CENTERS
SCHOOLS KEEPING CHILDREN AT
HOME AND MAKE IT EVEN MORE
DIFFICULT FOR PARENTS.
SPECIALLY FOR MOTHERS WHO TEND
TO BE THE PRIMARY CARRIERS KEEP
WORKING. THESE BURDENS THAT
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT THE
LONGER WOMEN OF COLOR. DURING
THE FIRST THREE MONTHS OF
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN EMPLOYMENT
FOR BLACK AND LATINA WOMEN FILE
FELL BY 20% MORE THAN TWO
THIRDS OF THE KLEIN AN
EMPLOYMENT FOR WHITE WOMEN AND
MORE THAN THREE TIMES OF THE
CLAIM FOR WHITE MEN. WOMEN'S
WORKPLACE EQUALITY WILL HAVE.
BEEN SET BACK DECADES BY THE
CRISIS. WELL AS WE ESTATE
LEADERS COME TOGETHER AND
INTERVENE TO AVERT IT. THERE
HAS NEVER BEEN A MORE IMPORTANT
TIME FOR LEADERSHIP DURING THE
CALL THE NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
TODAY WE CELEBRATE WOMEN'S
HISTORY MONTH AND WE MUST
CELEBRATED EVERY YEAR TO FOCUS
OUR ATTENTION ON THEIR
HISTORICAL ROLE IN
ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF THE
TRAILBLAZING WOMEN THAT CAME
BEFORE US. AND THOSE THAT WILL
COME AFTER US. TODAY WE
CELEBRATE AMAZING WOMEN FROM
EACH ASSEMBLY AND SENATE
DISTRICTS ARE WORKING DAY IN
AND DAY OUT. TO ME THE
COMMUNITIES AND OUR GOLDEN
STATE BETTER. IN BIG AND SMALL
WAYS NOTICED AND UNNOTICED.
LEADERS LIKE OUR HONOREES HAVE
INSPIRED AND CHANGE OUR
COMMUNITIES FOR THE BETTER. AND
GET THIS GOING THROUGH AND KEPT
US GOING THERE IN EXTREMELY
CHALLENGING TIMES. IT IS FOR
THAT REASON THAT WE DECIDED
THAT WE WOULD CONTINUE THIS
RECOGNITION THIS YEAR OTHER
CELEBRATIONS LOOK DIFFERENT
THAN PAST YEARS. THE
CERTIFICATES ARE HONOREES WILL
RECEIVE THE PICK THE ARTWORK OF
A BOOK BY SAID IN A SONG AND I
CALLED. HOW WE WON THE VOTE IN
THE IN NINETEEN ELEVEN. DAMAGE
RETRACE A WOMAN REPRESENTING
THE SIX STAR TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AS CALIFORNIA WAS A
SIXTY TO GIVE THE WOMEN THE
RIGHT TO VOTE. THIS COME
TOGETHER TO CELEBRATE ALL OF
OUR HONOREES THE TROUBLE IS THE
RAISING WOMEN IN THE PAST THE
HISTORY MAKING WOMEN THAT SERVE
WITH US TODAY AND THEY FEATURE
WOMEN WHO WILL CONTINUE TO
CATAPULT OUR STATE OF SOCIETY
FORWARD. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN FRIEDMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THIS RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER ON
BEHALF OF THE LEGISLATIVE
JEWISH CAUCUS I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF HR TWENTY SIX AND WOMEN'S
HISTORY MONTH. JEWISH WOMEN
HAVE BEEN AT THE CENTRE OF
RIGHTEOUSNESS FOR CENTURIES
FOLLOWING THE JEWISH TEACHINGS
THAT JUSTICE MERCY AND GOODNESS
ARE NOT TO BE HELD IN A VACUUM
BUT PRACTICE IN OUR DAILY
LIVES. WE HAVE STOOD
COURAGEOUSLY AT THE FOREFRONT
OF A WIDE RANGE PROGRESSIVE
CAUCUS CAUSES INCLUDING WOMEN'S
SUFFRAGE LABOUR REFORM CIVIL
RIGHTS SCIENTIFIC ADVANCEMENT
LITERATURE AND HEALTH CARE. WE
CAN COUNT AMONG THEIR RANKS
LEADERS IN EVERY FIELD
INCLUDING GERTRUDE ELION WHO
DEVELOPED THE FIRST TREATMENT
FOR CHILDHOOD LEUKEMIA AN ANTI
VIRAL MEDICATION AND THE
LAZARUS A SUCCESSFUL AUTHOR AND
POET WHOSE WORDS GIVE ME YOUR
TIRED YOUR POOR YOUR HUDDLED
MASSES YEARNING TO BE FREE. ARE
DISPLAYED ON THE STATUE OF
LIBERTY. AND WELCOMING- KNOWN
TO WELCOME NEWCOMERS TO AMERICA
FROM AROUND THE WORLD. ONE OF
MY PERSONAL FAVORITES BILL US
BUG OR BATTLING BELLA WHO
SERVED THREE TERMS IN CONGRESS
AND ADVOCATED FOR GROUND
BREAKING BILLS INCLUDING EQUAL
RIGHTS AMENDMENT ENTITLE NINE.
AND OF COURSE JUSTICE RUTH
BADER GINSBURG AND IKONEN
ARDENT DEFENDER OF EQUAL RIGHTS
AND REPRODUCTIVE CHOICE ON THE
SUPREME COURT. HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE NATION JEWISH WOMEN
HAVE NEVER STOOD IDLY BY
AGAINST OPPRESSION OR
pFORWARD TO A TIME WHEN WE DON'T
HAVE TO CELEBRATE WOMEN'S
HISTORY MONTH WHEN THE STORIES
OF WOMEN AND OUR
ACCOMPLISHMENTS IT'S SO MUCH A
PART OF OUR LEXICON AND TAUGHT
ON EQUAL FOOTING. AND
RECOGNIZED ALONGSIDE THAT OF
OUR BROTHERS I LOOK FORWARD TO
THE DAY WHEN WE WHEN WOMEN'S
HISTORY. IS RECOGNIZED SIMPLY
AS HUMAN HISTORY. THAT WON'T
HAPPEN THOUGH UNTIL WE HAVE A
TIME WHEN WOMEN IN GOVERNMENT
WHEN WOMEN IN BUSINESS WOMEN IN
THE ARTS WHEN WOMEN IN POWER IN
OUR SOCIETY. A PARITY WITH MEN.
RATHER THAN HAVING ONE MONTH
RECOGNIZING THAT GOAL THAT'LL
BE REALIZE ALL YEAR. THAT'S
WHEN WE KNOW THAT REAL JUSTICE
AND REALLY QUALITY HAS OCCURRED.
AS THE DAUGHTER OF A STRONG
JEWISH WOMAN AND THE
GRANDDAUGHTER OF A VERY STRONG
JEWISH BOOK WHO TOOK WITH ME
DOOR TOOK ME DOOR TO DOOR TO
ADVOCATE FOR WOMEN'S RIGHTS
WHEN I WAS A CHILD IN FLORIDA.
AND IS A PROUD JEWISH WOMAN
MYSELF I URGE AN AYE VOTE ON HR
TWENTY SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISS FRIEDMAN MISS BURKE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS I RISE TO SUPPORT HR
TWENTY SIX RELATIVE TO WOMEN'S
HISTORY MONTH. WE WOULD BE
REMISS IF WE DID NOT MENTION
DURING TODAY'S CELEBRATION THE
CONTRIBUTIONS AND ACHIEVEMENTS
OF BLACK WOMEN IN OUR STATE.
BLACK WOMEN HAVE SHATTERED
GLASS CEILINGS FOR YEARS
WORKING TEN TIMES HARDER AS
THEIR COUNTERPARTS WITH VERY
LITTLE RECOGNITION. AND IT'S
TIME FOR THAT TO CHANGE. FIFTY
FIVE YEARS AGO MY MOM WAS THE
FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMAN%
ELECTED TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LEGISLATURE. AND ACHIEVEMENT
THAT AT THE TIME WAS NOTHING
SHORT OF EXTRAORDINARY. IN OUR
TIME HERE SHE BECAME ONE OF THE
FOUNDERS OF THE LEGISLATIVE
WHACK MARKETS WHICH I AM A
PROUD MEMBER. SINCE THEN WE
HAVE SEEN MANY BLACK WOMEN
ACHIEVE MANY NEW BOLD HEIGHTS.
AMONG MANY NOTABLE WOMEN WE'VE
HAD KAREN BASS WAS THE FIRST
AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMAN IN THE
UNITED STATES HISTORY TO SERVE
AS SPEAKER. AT THE STATE
LEGISLATURE. SUE PARKER THE
FIRST WOMAN TO SERVE AS THE
CHIEF PART OF THIS ASSEMBLY.
AND DR SHIRLEY WEBER THE FIRST
AFRICAN AMERICAN TO SERVE AS A
CALIFORNIA STATE SECRETARY OF
STATE. HOWEVER I MUST SAY IT'S
NOT SIMPLY ENOUGH TO CELEBRATE
THE WINS. IF WE TRULY BELIEVE
IN EQUALITY. AND EQUITY WE MUST
ACCEPT RESPONSIBILITY FOR
ASSURING THAT WHEN ONE WOMAN A
SENSE IT DOESN'T EVEN EMPTY
SEATS ARE SILENCE THE VOICES OF
HALF OUR STATE POPULATION. THE
QUESTION IS NO LONGER CAN WE
LEAVE OR SHOULD WE LEAVE. BUT
HOW WILL EACH OF YOU MAKE SURE
THAT WOMEN ESPECIALLY WOMEN OF
COLOR CONTINUE TO OCCUPY THE
SEATS AROUND. IF WE DO THIS I
BELIEVE WILL BE INSPIRING
GENERATIONS TO REACH THEIR TRUE
POTENTIAL. FREE OF ANY SOCIETY
BARRIERS AND STANDARDS. WE'VE
COME A LONG WAY SINCE THE DAYS
WHEN WOMEN WERE NOT ALLOWED TO
VOTE BUT THE FIGHT FOR EQUALITY
IT'S NOT OVER. THE STRUGGLES OF
WOMEN THE RESOLVING THE MIGHT
SHOWN BY WOMEN IN OUR NATION'S
HISTORY WE WILL HAVE BEEN IN
PAIN IF WE DON'T ADDRESS THESE
CHALLENGES WOMEN FACE TODAY.
MORE MUST BE DONE TO SUPPORT
WOMEN AND WOMEN OF COLOR
LOOKING. STATION ACROSS ALL
LEVELS. AS WE HONOR AND
CELEBRATE WOMEN TODAY. LET US
REMEMBER TO CONTINUE TO BUILD
UPON THE LEGACY OF MANY WOMEN
THAT HAVE FOUGHT FOR THE
OPPORTUNITIES. THAT WE ALL
BENEFIT FROM TODAY. THANK YOU
MISS BURKE CERVANTES YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LGBTQ CAUCUS
I PROBABLY RISE IN SUPPORT OF
HR TWENTY SIX. AS A MEMBER OF
THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY THERE'S NO
DENYING THAT LESBIAN BISEXUAL
AND TRANSGENDER WOMEN HAVE MADE
NUMEROUS CONTRIBUTIONS IN OUR
SOCIETY. IN CALIFORNIA FIVE
POINT 4% OF THE FEMALE
POPULATION IDENTIFY AS LGBTQ.
AS A STATE WE HAVE MADE GREAT
STRIDES IN MOVING AWAY FROM
TRADITIONAL MALE FEMALE FEMALE
BINARY GENDER NORMS AND
RECOGNIZING SEXUAL IDENTITY AS
A FLUID CONTRIBUTOR TO LIVING
FREELY AND AUTHENTICALLY. WE
ARE DAUGHTERS WE ARE MOTHERS WE
ARE FRIENDS AND WE ARE ALLIES
IN OUR RESPECTIVE COMMUNITIES
AND THE CELEBRATION OF
WOMANHOOD HAS SHOWN US THAT
EVERY WOMAN HAS INCREDIBLE
POWER. WE MUST CONTINUE TO
HONOR THE ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF WE
ARE WOMEN WHO HAVE IGNITED
CHANGE THROUGH ACTIVISM THROUGH
LEADERSHIP EVEN IN THE FACE OF
SEXISM. AND ANTI LGBTQ RHETORIC
SADLY THERE IS STILL AN
EPIDEMIC OF VIOLENCE ATTACKING
TRANSGENDER WOMEN ESPECIALLY
ARE TRANSGENDER WOMEN OF COLOR.
IF FALLS UPON EACH OF US. EACH
OF US TO PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF
OUR TRANSGENDER SISTERS AND
ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE ACCESS
THE SAME ACCESS THE SAME
PRIVILEGE THAT WE ALL DO. MAY
WE ALWAYS ACKNOWLEDGE THE
LIVELIHOOD OF ALL WOMEN AS WE
ASPIRE EQUALITY FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS I PROBABLY RISE IN
SUPPORT AND ASK FOR I BILL FOR
EACH R. TWENTY SIX. THANK YOU
MESS AROUND WITH. HELLO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I
RISE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS AND
HONORING SOME DYNAMIC ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER WOMEN
INCLUDING FIONA MA A CERTIFIED
PUBLIC ACCOUNTANT CURRENTLY
SERVING AS OUR STATE'S TREASURE
OR BETTY CURRENTLY SERVING HER
SECOND TERM AS THE STATE
COMPTROLLER ONLY THE TENTH
WOMAN IN CALIFORNIA HISTORY TO
BE ELECTED TO STATEWIDE OFFICE
OR EVEN OUR VERY OWN MAINLY TOM
A PIONEER. AS THE FIRST WOMAN
AND FIRST ETHNIC MINORITY TO
SERVE AT THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE AS-PREVIOUSLY NOTED AS CHIEF
ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICER FROM
THIS VERY BODY THIS IS WHY WE
CELEBRATE TODAY RECOGNIZING THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF SO MANY ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER WOMEN BUT IT'S
ABUNDANTLY CLEAR WE HAVE MUCH
WORK TO BE DONE AND I ALSO WANT
TO RECOGNIZE OUR COLLEAGUES IN
THIS LEGISLATURE ASSEMBLYWOMAN
JANET NGUYEN AT TO CONTINUE ON
THE PIPELINE DEVELOPMENT OF ALL
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER WOMEN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MR LOW SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE RESOLUTION MISTER IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE. YES THANK
YOU I WANT TO CLOSE BY
RECOGNIZING SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE RUTH BADER GINSBURG WHO
WOULD HAVE TURNED EIGHTY EIGHT
YEARS OLD TODAY. FINITARY IS
RBG LISTA WARRIOR AND AS ROLE
MODEL FOR EVERYONE SPECIALLY
FOR WOMEN. FOR INTELLIGENCE AND
CORE VALUES THAT PAVE THE PATH
FOR CIVIL AND EQUAL RIGHTS FOR
WOMEN. PHILARMONIC UNITED
STATES VERSUS VIRGINIA WHICH
SHE AUTHORED AND THE GENDER
SEGREGATION IN PUBLIC
INSTITUTIONS AND IS WIDELY SEEN
AS THE PRESIDENT FOR EVERY
GENDER EQUITY VICTORY THAT
FOLLOWED. IN THE HISTORY OF THE
SUPREME COURT THERE HAVE BEEN A
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN JUSTICES
ONLY FIVE HAVE BEEN WOMEN. NO
JUSTICE HAD A GREATER IMPACT ON
NARROWING THE GENDER GAP IN THE
NOTORIOUS RBG SHE'S A HERO TO
MANY INCLUDING MYSELF. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE FIRST WILL
BE OPEN FOR COLLECTORS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER FEAR THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
COOPER ON HR TWENTY SIX THE
RULE IS OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS ON
HR TWENTY SIX ALL MEMBERS VOTED
A THIRD OF IT. THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. WHERE TWELVE
THE ROLE IN THE THERE ARE
SEVENTY TWO COOPER MANAGER
TWENTY SIX WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
ALL OPPOSED SAY NO THE AYES
HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. WE WILL PASS AND
RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS TWO AND
THREE.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
TAKE UP SB NINETY FIVE WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE THE CLERK
WILL READ. SENATE BILL NINETY
FIVE BY SOON SKINNER AN ACT
RELATING TO EMPLOYMENT MAKING A
PROBATIONER FOR TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BE RELATED TO THE
BUDGET. THIRTEEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THE MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
REPRESENT U. S. B. NINETY FIVE
ARE PAID SICK LEAVE BILL. COVER
NINETEEN RATES ARE. OVER NINETY
KIDS WHICH ARE SME PROVING.
BUT THE VIRUS IS STILL VERY
MUCH IN CERTAIN COMMUNITIES.
THIS BILL WILL HELP MAKE IT AN
EASIER CHOICE FOR EMPLOYEES OF
BUSINESSES WHO ARE SICK.
THEY'LL HAVE TO DECIDE WHETHER
TO GET A PAYCHECK OR TO HAVE TO
GO TO WORK TO FURTHER SPREAD.
THE VIRUS THE BILL'S
REESTABLISHES TWO WEEKS. AGO
BUT NINETEENTH SUPPLEMENTAL
PAID SICK LEAVE. FOR EMPLOYEES
WITH MORE THAN WITH A FOR A
WITH EMPLOYERS WITH MORE THAN
TWENTY FIVE EMPLOYEES INTEL.
SEPTEMBER THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. IT PROVIDES PAID
SICK LEAVE FOR WORKERS WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING SYMPTOMS OF
COVERED NINETEEN. AND ARE
SEEKING A MEDICAL DIAGNOSIS.
BUT TO PLEASE REFER TO
QUARANTINE. TWO ONES ARE
GETTING VACCINATED OR EXPERTS
EXISTS SYMPTOMS FROM THE
VACCINE. OR IF THEY NEED TO
TAKE LEAVE TO TAKE CARE OF A
FAMILY MEMBER WHO MAY HAVE
CALLED IT. OUR RECENT
AMENDMENTS ARE ALIGNED WITH THE
FAMILIES FIRST CORONAVIRUS
RESPONSE AFTER THE AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN. WHICH WAS JUST
SIGNED BY PRESIDENT BIDEN.
COMPANIES WITH FIVE HUNDRED OR
LESS EMPLOYEES ARE ELIGIBLE TO
RECEIVE FEDERAL DOLLARS FOR
DOLLAR TAX CREDITS. IF THEY
OFFER BASICALLY FOR THE
EMPLOYEES AND TELL MARCH THIRTY
FIRST. AND UNDER THE AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN PROVIDES A NEW POOL
OF TAX CREDITS. UNTIL SEPTEMBER
THIRTIETH. S. SO IN ESSENCE SB
NINETY FIVE WILL PROVIDE.
APPROXIMATELY ALL TO POSSIBLY
TEN POINT FOR CALIFORNIA
WORKERS PAID SICK LEAVE WITHOUT
A RESPECT FOR YES PRIVATE ON S.
B. NINETY FIVE. THANK YOU MR
CHANG MR FONG YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. I THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. A MEMBERS I RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB NINETY FIVE.
THIS BODY RECENTLY PASSED THE
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESS
COVERED NINETEEN RELIEF GRANT
PROGRAM TO HELP CALIFORNIA
SMALL BUSINESSES KEEP
CALIFORNIANS WORKING IN ONE OF
THE MOST DAUNTING AND
CHALLENGING CIRCUMSTANCES THEY
FACE IN THEIR LIFETIMES. OUR
LOCAL SMALL BUSINESSES HAVE
TOLD US. THAT WHAT WOULD BE THE
MOST HELPFUL TO THEM IT'S A PUT
A PAUSE ON IMPOSING MORE COSTS
AND BURDENS ON THEM BUT THEY
ARE TRYING TO OPEN UP. REHIRE
AND RECOVER. BUT THIS BILL DOES
EXACTLY THE OPPOSITE BY
IMPOSING EVEN MORE REQUIREMENTS
ON BUSINESSES EXPOSING THEM TO
EVEN MORE LIABILITY. WITH SMALL
BUSINESSES SIMPLY TRYING TO
SURVIVE THIS IS ANOTHER BLOW
THEY WILL TRY TO ENSURE PILING
ON OUR SMALL BUSINESSES WHO IN
FACT POWER OUR LOCAL ECONOMIES
WILL ONLY STAND IN THE WAY OF
OUR ECONOMIC RECOVERY. AND HERE
WE ARE WITH THOUSANDS OF CLOSE
BUSINESSES IN OUR STATE
MILLIONS UNEMPLOYED YES
SACRAMENTO IS YET PUMMELING OUR
SMALL BUSINESS COMMUNITY WITH
MORE RESTRICTIONS AND
BURDENSOME REQUIREMENTS ON
BUSINESSES THAT HAVE PERSEVERED
TO THIS PANDEMIC I URGE A NO
VOTE ON SB NINETY FIVE. THANK
YOU MR FONG MYSTERY ARE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THE MATTER. MMHM
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS FIRST I WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU TO ALL THE
MEMBERS OF THIS BODY WHO PRO
ACTIVELY REACHED OUT AND WANTED
TO WORK ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT
MEASURE. IN THE LAST FEW WEEKS
WE HAVE ENGAGED IN DIALOGUE ASK
QUESTIONS DISAGREED COME TO
AGREEMENT SEARCH FOR ANSWERS
AND ULTIMATELY CAME TO AN
AGREEMENT AND A COMPROMISE.
THEY SAY THAT WHEN LEGISLATION
MOVES FORWARD AND NO ONE PARTY
IS 1100% HAPPY THEN YOU'RE
DOING SOMETHING RIGHT. AND
THAT'S WHAT COMPROMISE LOOKS
LIKE. IT HAS BEEN AN EXPERIENCE
TO SAY THE LEAST AND ONE THAT I
THINK WE ARE AT A POINT WHERE
WE CAN ALL SUPPORT. AS WE ENTER
THE ONE YEAR ANNIVERSARY OF THE
CULVERT NINETEEN GLOBAL
PANDEMIC AND THE SHUTDOWN THAT
HAS UPENDED OUR LIVES WE ALL
NEED TIME TO REFLECT. AS WELL
AS MOVE FORWARD TOWARD THE
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL THAT IS
INCLUSIVE EQUITABLE AND
TRANSPARENT. THAT INCLUDES
INSURING THAT THE GOLDEN
STIMULUS THAT HAS. THAT WE HAVE
ALREADY PASSED IN THIS BODY IS
SUCCESSFUL. AND THAT WE ALSO
PROTECT THE EMPLOYEES WHICH
MAKES SMALL BUSINESSES FUNCTION
ACROSS CALIFORNIA AND REALLY
ACROSS THIS NATION WE ALL KNOW
AND AGREE. THAT SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE THE BACKBONE OF
THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMY I HAVE
BUSINESSES IN MY DISTRICT THAT
ARE FACING SHUTDOWNS THAT ARE
FACING SHUTDOWNS BECAUSE OF
GENTRIFICATION THAT ARE FACING
SHUTDOWNS. BECAUSE OF HIGH
RENTS IN COMMERCIAL PROPERTIES
THAT DON'T HAVE ANY PROTECTIONS
AT THE MOMENT THE LAST THING
THAT WE WANT IS TO HAVE THE
SMALL BUSINESSES IN OUR
COMMUNITIES FAILED. BUT WE
CANNOT DO SO IF WE ALSO DON'T
PROTECT THE WORKERS THE
EMPLOYEES FROM OUR COMMUNITY
THAT MAKE THOSE SMALL
BUSINESSES WORK. EVERY SINGLE
DAY ONE PERSON GETTING COVERED
AND BRINGING COLD INTO THE
WORKPLACE IS A ONE PERSON TOO
MANY IMPACTING THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THEIR COWORKERS AND
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY. OF THE
CUSTOMERS OF THAT SMALL
BUSINESS. WELL MANY
CALIFORNIANS WERE ABLE TO STAY
HOME AND QUARANTINE. AND ORDER
GROCERIES ONLINE LET US
REMEMBER THAT THOSE GROCERIES
WERE PICKED UP AND DELIVERED BY
A REAL HUMAN BEING. THE GROCERY
STORE WAS STOCKED AND CLEANED
BY A REAL HUMAN BEING. THE
GROCERIES WERE BROUGHT TO THAT
STORE THROUGH A TRUCK BY A REAL
HUMAN BEING. FOOD WAS PICKED UP
AND PACKAGED BY A REAL HUMAN
BEING THESE ARE REAL HUMAN
LIVES HUMANS WHO HAVE BEEN
ESSENTIAL. AND YOU HAVE SHOWN
US WHAT MANY OF US ALREADY KNEW
WHEN IT COMES TO BE ECONOMIC
INEQUITIES OF THIS COUNTRY AND
OUR STATE. OUR CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY IS DRIVEN BY HARD
WORKING PEOPLE WHO HAVE FOR THE
PAST YEAR WRISTER LIVES WELL WE
SURVIVED A GLOBAL PANDEMIC. BUT
WHEN THE INEVITABLE HAPPENS AND
A WORKER CONTRACTS SILVA
NINETEEN. WE SHOULD MAKE SURE
THAT THAT CHOICE BETWEEN A
PAYCHECK. AND RISKING THE
HEALTH OF THEIR COWORKERS AND
THEIR CUSTOMERS ISN'T THE
CHOICE CALIFORNIA NEED
SUPPLEMENTAL COVERED NINETEEN
PAPERS THAT SICK LEAVE. THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PROVIDES TAX
CREDITS FOR SMALL AND MIDSIZE
BUSINESSES THAT VOLUNTARILY
PROVIDE SICK LEAVE TO THEIR
EMPLOYEES BUT ONCE AGAIN. WE
MUST ACT WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FALLS SHORT SB
NINETY FIVE. DOES EXEMPTS.
BUSINESSES THAT ARE SMALLER
THAN TWENTY FIVE EMPLOYEES AND
UNDER AND I URGE ALL OF YOU WHO
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT YOUR SMALL
BUSINESSES. THAT WE WORK
TOGETHER TO ENSURE THAT THOSE
SMALL BUSINESSES WITH TWENTY
FIVE AND UNDER KNOW THAT THEY
CAN STILL PROVIDE THIS
INCREDIBLE AND NECESSARY
BENEFITS TO THEIR WORKERS WITH
THE STIMULUS FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. AND I REALLY DO
HOPE THAT ALL OF YOU THAT SAY
YOU CARE ABOUT YOUR SMALL
BUSINESSES. WORK WITHIN THIS
BODY TO ENSURE THAT THOSE
TWENTY FIVE AND UNDER LET ME
SAY IT AGAIN TWENTY FIVE AND
UNDER WHO WE ARE ACCEPTING.
HAVE ACCESS AND KNOWLEDGE AND
RESOURCES TO LET THEIR
EMPLOYEES KNOW THAT THEY CAN
STILL RECEIVE THE PAID LEAVE
BASED ON WHAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS ALREADY DOING. I
WILL LEAVE YOU WITH THIS AND
SAY REQUIRING PAID SICK LEAVE
FOR WORKERS WILL HELP PREVENT
THE SPREAD AND SAVE LIVES MORE
THAN HALF A MILLION AMERICANS
HAVE LOST. HALF A MILLION
AMERICANS HAVE A MILLION
AMERICANS HAVE LOST THEIR LIVES
DUE TO THE PANDEMIC. MORE THAN
FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ALONE
SECOND WE CANNOT WAIT WE HAVE
TO ACT TODAY AND WE MUST
ENSURE. THAT MORE LIVES ARE
LOST AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE FOR SB NINETY FIVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISCREANT
MISTER SMITH YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
ON THE MATTER. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. AS A FRESHMAN TO THIS
LEGISLATOR IN A RETIRED
BUSINESS OWNER. I STAND OPPOSED
TO S. B. NINETY FIVE. THERE'S
OVER FORTY CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE'S THAT ARE OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL TO. REPRESENTING
HUNDREDS OF BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA. WE ARE MAKING A
POLICY CHANGE THROUGH A BUDGET
BILL. THAT'S NOT HOW IT'S
SUPPOSED TO BE. WE COULD HAVE
AN EMERGENCY BILL BE MORE
TRANSPARENT TO THE RESIDENTS OF
CALIFORNIA GIVE THEM MORE TIME
FOR INPUT. SO THEIR VOICES
HEARD IN CALIFORNIA. WE'VE ALL
HEARD THE SAYING BEFORE. I'M
FROM THE GOVERNMENT AND I'M
HERE TO HELP. WHAT BUSINESSES
NEED TO CALIFORNIA THE FORMER
GOVERNMENT TO QUIT TRYING TO
HELP. BECAUSE ALL WE DO IS KEEP
MAKING IT WORSE I STAND OPPOSED
TO IT SB NINETY FIVE. THANK YOU
MISTER SMITH. THIS RESCUE WERE
RECOGNIZED ON THE MATTER. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER. I RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB. EIGHTY
FOUR SB NINETY FIVE AS THIS
MEASURE IS A BALANCED APPROACH
TO PROTECT OUR SMALL BUSINESSES
AND ENSURE OUR CENTRAL WORKERS
WHO HAVE BEEN THE BACKBONE OF
CALIFORNIA DURING THE COPA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAVE ACCESS
TO CRITICAL PAID SICK LEAVE
BENEFITS. EMPLOYERS SHOULD NOT
FEEL AS THOUGH THEIR ABILITY TO
PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE OR PAID
FOR A ROOF OVER THEIR HEAD THAT
IS RELIANT ON THEM IGNORING
PUBLIC HEALTH. AND SAFETY
ORDERS. THE AMERICAN RESCUE
PLAN SIGNED BY PRESIDENT JOE
BIDEN WILL REIMBURSE. CUPBOARD
EMPLOYERS FOR THE COST OF
PROVIDING SICK LEAVE. WE NEED
TO SUPPORT OUR SMALL BUSINESSES.
AND WE NEED TO SUPPORT OUR
CENTRAL WORKERS AND MITIGATE
THE SPREAD OF COVERT NINETEEN.
CALIFORNIA IS LOOKING AT US AND
DEPENDING ON OUR COMPASSION AND
OUR COMMON SENSE TO ENSURE
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY. LET'S
SHOW THEM WE WILL FIGHT FOR
THEM I URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR SB
NINETY FIVE. THANK YOU MISS
RASMUSSEN COLLEGE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. I RISE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND I HAVE
TO ASK MY COLLEAGUES CAN YOU
IMAGINE CAN YOU IMAGINE US
HAVING AN OPPORTUNITY TO PASS A
POLICY THAT WILL LITERALLY SAVE
THE LIVES OF WORKERS IN OUR
DISTRICT. SAVE THE LIVES
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN TAKING THE TIME
OFF IF THEY'RE COVERED POSITIVE
AND PAYING THE BILLS IT WILL
ULTIMATELY SAVE THE LIVES OF
THOSE IN THE COMMUNITY THAT
THEY DON'T COME THEY DON'T
SPREAD IT THROUGHOUT THE SMALL
BUSINESSES. AND ON TOP OF THAT
IT'S ALL PAID FOR BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. THESE
BUSINESSES THAT ARE PROVIDING
THE SICK LEAVE WILL ACTUALLY BE
ABLE TO HAVE IT RECOUPED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. WE CAN SAVE
LIVES IN THIS IS. YOU KNOW WE
CAN TALK ABOUT TIME AND PROCESS
WE DON'T LIKE THE GOVERNOR TO
AN EXECUTIVE ORDER SO WE'RE
PUTTING THROUGH A PROCESS BUT
WE DON'T HAVE MUCH MORE TIME.
DESPITE THE VACCINES DESPITE
THE SLOW THE SPREAD PEOPLE IN
OUR COMMUNITIES ARE STILL
TIENE. WORKERS THAT HAVE NO
PROTECTIONS ARE STILL GOING TO
WORK SICK. THIS WILL PREVENT
THAT THIS WILL SAVE LIVES AT
ZERO COST TO OUR BUSINESSES. IT
IS A WIN WIN. WE HEARD YOUR
CALLS ABOUT WORRYING ABOUT
SMALL BUSINESSES. IN TWENTY
FIVE AND UNDER ARE TAKEN OUT
DESPITE THE FACT THAT THEY
TOOL. CAN GET A TAX REFUND OR
TAX CREDIT FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. WE SHOULD ENCOURAGE
ALL OF OUR BUSINESSES. TO
ACCESS THIS VERY IMPORTANT
PROCESS THROUGH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. BUT WE SHOULD
DEMAND. THAT THOSE THAT CAN DO
PROVIDE IT. I SAY TODAY THAT
THERE IS NO WAY THAT A BUSINESS
WITH OVER TWENTY FIVE PEOPLE
CAN'T FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET THE
TAX CREDIT FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. IT'S TIME TO SAVE
LIVES. I IMPLORE YOU ON BEHALF
OF THE COMMUNITY MEMBERS IN MY
DISTRICT. IN MISCREANTS DESPITE
MY COLLEAGUE FROM LA. MY OTHER
COLLEAGUES FROM LOS ANGELES AS
WE HAVE BEEN WITNESSING THEM
DYING BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN
FORCED TO GO TO WORK I IMPLORE
YOU TO DO. SOME RELIEF FOR
THOSE WORKERS WE HAVE CALLED
THE ESSENTIAL WORKERS. DO THIS
ONE SMALL THING TO ALLOW THEM
TO BE ABLE TO WORK AND GO HOME
SAFELY WHEN THEY ARE SICK. AYE
ASPIRIN AYE ABOUT. THANK YOU
MISS GONZALEZ.
YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU I RISE
TODAY IN OPPOSITION OF F. B.
NINETY FIVE ONE YEAR AND TWO
DAYS AGO MANY OF THE BUSINESSES
IN MY COMMUNITY CLOSE THEIR
DOORS TO DO THEIR PART AND
FLATTENING THE CURVE AND
FIGHTING THIS PANDEMIC I'M
REMINDED OF THE LATINO OWN
BUSINESS OF MY COMMUNITY THEY
MAKE JERSEYS FOR ATHLETIC TEAMS
IN OUR COMMUNITY. THEY CLOSE
THEIR DOORSBUT QUICKLY PIVOTED
TO MAKING MASK AND FLOOR DECALS
TO HELP OTHER ESSENTIAL
BUSINESSES MARKED THE GROUND
FOR SOCIAL DISTANCING OTHER
BUSINESSES HAD TO FURLOUGH
EMPLOYEES BUT KEPT PAYING FOR
THEIR HEALTH INSURANCE THERE
ARE SO THEIR EMPLOYEES WERE NOT
WITHOUT HEALTH INSURANCE IN THE
MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC. SOME
COMPANIES CLOSE ONE YEAR AGO
AND THEY HAVE YET TO OPEN THEIR
DOORS LIKE SIX FLAGS MAGIC
MOUNTAIN AND DODGER STADIUM
THAT HAVE OPENED THEIR SITES TO
HELP ADMINISTER VACCINES SO
MANY BUSINESSES ALONGSIDE THEIR
EMPLOYEES HAVE STEPPED UP TO
THE PLATE DURING THIS PANDEMIC
FOR THE DAY CARE PROVIDER WITH
ONE EMPLOYEE TO THE FILTRATION
COMPANY WITH FORTY EMPLOYEES TO
OUR THEME PARKS AND SPORTS
VENUES. WITH THOUSANDS OF
EMPLOYEES THEY'RE ALL AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THE FABRIC
THAT MAKES CALIFORNIA A
WONDERFUL PLACE TO LIVE AND DO
BUSINESS WE SHOULD BE
SUPPORTING THEM AT EVERY
OPPORTUNITY LET'S REWARD THEIR
COMMITMENT NOT PENALIZE THEM BY
OPENING UP THEM UP TO LAWSUITS
TO THE RETROACTIVE LANGUAGE IN
THIS BILL BUSINESSES ARE FRAUD
TRIAL AND THIS BILL WILL KILL
BUSINESSES AND JOBS. I URGE YOU
TO VOTE NO THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
FOR MISTER JONES SAWYER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINETY FIVE. MANY BUSINESSES IN
MY DISTRICT. OUR SIDEWALK
VENDORS THE SIDEWALK VENDORS
PROBABLY ARE THE ONES THAT
EMPLOY THE MOST PEOPLE N. A. D.
FIFTY NINE. EIGHTY FIFTY NINE
ALSO HAS UNIVERSITY SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA MY ALMA MATER. THIS
BILL IS NOT FOR THAT LARGE
UNIVERSITY IS ACTUALLY FOR.
INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE LESS THAN
TWENTY FIVE EMPLOYEES. THAT
EVERY DAY. EVERY DAY THEY HAVE
TO SUPPORT NOT ONLY THEIR
BUSINESS BUT THE FAMILIES THAT
THE EMPLOYEE. THE MOST
IMPORTANT THEY DON'T HAVE GOOD
LOBBYIST TO COME UP HERE TO
SACRAMENTO THEY DON'T HAVE.
LARGE ACCOUNTANTS DON'T HAVE
ATTORNEYS THAT CAN FIGHT FOR
THEM WITH THE IRS THEY'RE JUST
VERY SMALL BEGINNING.
BUSINESSES MOSTLY LATINO
BUSINESSES. FOR WHICH THIS BILL
WILL ACTUALLY HELP BECAUSE
THEY'VE BEEN CARVED OUT THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO BE IMPACTED
BECAUSE IF YOU'RE TWENTY FIVE
EMPLOYEES OR LESS. YOU'RE NOT
IMPACTED SO WHEN I HEAR. THAT
THIS WILL HURT SMALL BUSINESSES.
I HAVE SMALL BUSINESSES WHEN
YOU'RE ONE OR TWO. A TWENTY
FIVE PLEASE LESS THAT'S A SMALL
BUSINESS. IN THIS BILL WILL
HELP MAKE SURE THAT THE
EMPLOYEES ARE KEPT SAFE THEY
COULD STAY AND CN DO THINGS
THAT THEY NEED TO DO BUT MOST
IMPORTANT THEY'RE NOT ADVERSELY
IMPACTED BY THIS BILL SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER JOHN
SORRY MR CALL ARE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND TO MY COLLEAGUES
THAT HAS SPOKEN IN SUPPORT OF
SB NINETY FIVE. I WANT TO
FOLLOW UP ON COMMENTS FROM OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO.
REGARDING THE FACT THAT THIS
REALLY IS ABOUT LIFE AND DEATH
FOR SO MANY. IN OUR STATE. AND
THAT CANNOT- IN THAT THAT THAT
THAT YOU CAN GET THAT BACK YOU
KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF RESOURCES
COMING IN FEDERAL BRING A LOT
OF RESOURCES IN THE STATE- TO
TRY TO HELP ALL OF OUR
BUSINESSES SMALL MEDIUM LARGE
STAY IN BUSINESS WILL BE CAN'T
GET BACK ON THE LIVES LOST JUST
OVER THE WEEKEND THERE WAS AN
ARTICLE ABOUT. LATINO COMMUNITY
IN THE BAY AREA AND HOW MANY OF
THEM HAVE LOST THEIR LIVES. AND
THAT AS WE WERE RE OPENING.
LAST SPRING LOS AFTER LAST
SUMMER RE OPENING INTO THE FALL.
THE RE OPENING BENEFITTED THOSE
THAT WERE ABLE. TO WORK FROM
HOME IT WAS BENEFITING THOSE
WHO RE ABLE TO SOCIALLY
DISTANCE IT WAS NOT BENEFITING
THOSE THAT LIVED. WITH MULTIPLE
FAMILY MEMBERS AND A HOME IT
WAS NOT BENEFITING THOSE THAT
HAD NO CHOICE BUT TO GO TO
WORK. OR THEY WOULD GET FIRED
DIDN'T GET. SICK DAYS. AND SO.
AS THE VOTE ON THIS BILL TODAY.
THERE'S NO DOUBT THERE'S A LOT
THAT WE CAN DO TO SUPPORT OUR
BUSINESSES THAT WE HAVE BEEN
DOING LET'S NOT FORGET THAT IS
THOSE WORKERS THAT WORK FOR
THOSE BUSINESSES THAT ARE
LITERALLY PUTTING THEIR LIVES
ON THE LINE THE DATA HAS MADE
IT VERY CLEAR LET'S GET BEYOND
THE DATA TO THE ACTUAL PEOPLE
IN OUR COMMUNITIES. THE LOST
THEIR LOVED ONES JUST BECAUSE
THEY HAD TO GO TO WORK AND HAD
NO OTHER ALTERNATIVE. WITHOUT
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE ON SB
NINETY FIVE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER KALRA MR MCCARTY YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER YOU KNOW WE HAD THIS
CONVERSATION EARLIER THIS
MORNING IN THE FULL BUDGET
COMMITTEE CHAIRED BY OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
AND WE LOOK ABOUT THE IMPACT OF
WORKERS WHO DIED BECAUSE OF
EXPOSURE IN THE WORKPLACE YOU
THINK OF LARGE- POULTRY
MANUFACTURERS- THE GARMENT
INDUSTRY IN INDIA IN LOS
ANGELES A FARMWORKERS IN THE
FIELD. BUT MANY OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS COME FROM SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT YOU'VE NEVER
HEARD OF THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT IN
THE NEWS BECAUSE THEY EMPLOY
HUNDREDS OR- MULTIPLE HUNDREDS
OR A THOUSAND PEOPLE FROM THESE
LOCATIONS THESE ARE SMALL
ENTITIES. AND AMID AND SOME
PEOPLE WOULD SAY THIS BILL
DOESN'T GO FAR ENOUGH I RE I
REMIND PEOPLE WHO DON'T LIKE
THIS AND WHO WERE OPPOSED TO
LAST YEAR'S BILL. ON EXTENDING
PAID FAMILY LEAVE- THAT
THRESHOLD WITH FIVE OR FEWER
EMPLOYEES WHO WHO WEREN'T- WHO
WEREN'T OBLIGATED TO FOCUS ON
THIS THIS IS TWENTY FIVE OR
MORE. SO THERE'S A LOT OF
PEOPLE IN OUR COMMUNITY THAT
SAY THAT THIS DOES NOT GO FAR
ENOUGH. THEY WOULD WANT TO GO
DOWN FROM 222-215-2102 FIVE TO
ONE BECAUSE ANYTIME YOU HAVE AN
EMPLOYEE. THAT SIX THAT'S
EXPOSED TO COVER NINETEEN AND
IS FORCED TO GO TO WORK THEY'RE
PUTTING THEMSELVES IN THE
COMMUNITY AND LEE AT RISK SO I
WOULD SAY THAT THIS IS A FAIR
COMPROMISE. THIS IS A FAIR
COMPROMISE I APPLIED MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES WHO
WORKED ON THE AMENDMENTS AS
CHAIR THE BUDGET SUB COMMUNITY
REFORM STATE ADMINISTRATION.
FOR FINDING A FAIR NUMBER IN
THERE. BUT TWO OTHER THINGS I
THINK CAN'T GO IGNORED- ONE
WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS
GLOBAL PANDEMIC IT'S WINDING
DOWN THE VACCINES ARE ROLLING
OUT- BY THE BY THE FIRST OF MAY
EVERY ADULT IN AMERICA. IS
GOING TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
HAVE A VACCINE. CLINIC HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AS WELL. SO WE KNOW
THAT THE END IS NEAR THIS HAS A
SUNSET OF SEVERAL MONTHS DOWN
THE ROAD AT THE END OF
SEPTEMBER. AND THEN LASTLY- THE
CERTAINLY THIS IS MONEY THAT'S
ARE REFUNDABLE AS OUR MAJORITY
LEADER ALLUDED TO WITH- MONIES
IN THIS THIRD ROUND OF STIMULUS
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SO-
THE DIFF BURDEN ON BUSINESSES
IT IS AGAIN. MITIGATED WITH THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THIS-
FUNDED SO I THINK THIS WAS A
FAIR FAIR COMPROMISE. IS TIME
TO SUPPORT THIS MEASURE SUPPORT
OUR WORKERS BUT ALSO SUPPORT
PUBLIC HEALTH. WHICH IS WHY
THIS IS THE APPROPRIATE MEASURE
FOR CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MR MCCARTY MISTER LEE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB NINETY
FIVE BECAUSE FRANKLY. ALMOST A
YEAR AGO WHEN THIS PANDEMIC
STARTED WHAT WAS THE TERM THAT
WE C<c.cyan>G FOR GROCERY WORKERS</c>
ARE FOOD SERVICE WORKERS AND
EVERYONE THAT MADE SERVICE
ECONOMY AND ARE COMING FRANKLY
WORK. ASCENTIAL WORKERS
ASCENTIAL. IF WE DO NOT
GUARANTEE THEM PAID SICK LEAVE
WE ARE MAKING WORKERS CHOOSE
BETWEEN GETTING COVERED
NINETEEN OR THEIR PAYCHECK.
CHOOSE BETWEEN HAVING BEING
ABLE TO PAY THEIR RENT OR
PERHAPS GETTING A DEADLY VIRUS.
I HEAR FROM MY CONSTITUENTS ALL
THE TIME IT COMES OF COMES TO
MIND IS THERE WAS A BAKERY IN
MY DISTRICT. WHERE THERE WAS A
WORKER. WHO'S AFRAID TO GET
TESTED. THEY WERE VERY
IRRESPONSIBLE BUT THEY'RE
AFRAID TO GET TESTED BECAUSE
THEY DID NOT WANT TO HAVE TO
MISS WORK AND GUESS WHAT
HAPPENED VERY PREDICTABLE. THEY
CAME TO WORK AND EVICTED
EVERYONE SOME PEOPLE OUT SHE
WENT TO THE HOSPITAL AND THAT
BUSINESS HAD TO SHUT DOWN FOR
WEEKS FOR WEEKS. AND THAT IS
INCOME THAT HURTS THE FAMILY
SMALL BUSINESS BUT THEY ARE
TAKING MORE PRECAUTIONS THAN
EVER AND UNDERSTANDING THAT
THEY CANNOT HAVE THEIR
EMPLOYEES MAKE THAT CHOICE
BECAUSE IF THEY HAVE TO MAKE
THAT CHOICE. YOU'D RATHER. IT
RATHER CHOOSE YOUR YOUR
IMMINENT SURVIVAL. THAN AND
ROLL THE DICE ON A ON A VIRUS
AND THAT'S NOT HOW IT SHOULD BE
TO HELP COULD BE. I HAVE
WORKERS IN MY DISTRICT WHO WORK
AT RETAIL MALLS AND RETAIL
SHOPS. THAT ARE UPHOLD EARLIER
DURING THE SURGE WHEN WE RAISE
THE CAPACITIES AND THEY WERE
AFRAID TO GET TESTED. BECAUSE
THOSE WORKERS WHO WORK AT THE
RESTAURANTS AND WORK AT STORES
ARE THE ONES WHO CYCLE AND SEE
LOTS OF CUSTOMERS AND THEY'RE
THE ONES WHO POTENTIALLY. COULD
GET CALVET. AND YET THE SAME
TIME EVEN THOUGH THE EXPOSURE
IS HIGH AND THEY KNOW IT
THEY'RE FREE TO GET TESTED. BE
SIMPLY THERE WAS NO SOCIAL
SAFETY NET FOR THESE PEOPLE
THERE WAS NO PAID SICK LEAVE.
AND I'M- FRANKLY YOU KNOW OF
COURSE THAT WE HEAR FROM A LOT
OF PEOPLE LIKE MY COLLEAGUE IN
SACRAMENTO MENTIONED THAT THERE
A LOT OF FOLKS WHO WANT TO SEE
THIS GO DOWN FURTHER FROM
TWENTY FIVE. TO TWENTY FOUR
PERHAPS THE. 232-221-2019.
EIGHTEEN SEVENTEEN SIXTEEN
FIFTEEN FOURTEEN FIFTEEN
THIRTY. LOWER AMOUNTS SO THAT
PEOPLE COULD ACTUALLY BE
COVERED. LOWER SMALL BUSINESSES
AND EVERYONE SHOULD BE ABLE. TO
BE COVERED. BY BASICALLY.
EVERYONE BUT I'M GLAD THAT WE
HAVE A FAIR. PROCESS RIGHT NOW
OF FAIR BILL THAT'S A GOOD
COMPROMISE AND ADDS OUR
COLLEAGUES POINTED OUT WE HAVE
A PARTNER IN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT NOW. THAT WILL HELP
REIMBURSE AND SUPPORT SMALL
BUSINESSES AND PROTECT WORKERS
AT SAME TIME IT'S QUITE
TRANSFORMATIVE NOW TO HAVE A-
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. THAT
ACTUALLY PARTNERS WITH US AND
HELPS US WITH WORKING
CALIFORNIANS. AND WE SHOULD BE
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THAT AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE AND CLEVERLY
PUTTING TOGETHER LEGISLATION
LIKE THIS. SO REALLY AREN'T
YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS FOR ALL
THE WORKING CLASS CALIFORNIANS
NOT JUST IN. THE BAY AREA BUT
ALSO OF COURSE ALL THE ENTIRE
CALIFORNIA AND WE REALLY NEED
TO BE PASSING SICK LEAVE. NOW
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
MYSTERY MR SANTIAGO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. I THANK YOU MAY I
SPEAK I RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINETY FIVE. NOT JUST BECAUSE
IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO DO BE
THAT BECAUSE IT'S THE HUMANE
THING TO DO. THINK ABOUT IT NOT
EVERYBODY WAS LUCKY ENOUGH. TO
STAY AT HOME AND WORK FROM HOME.
NOT NOT EVERY CAN OAK UP. A
COMPUTER AT HOME. WE TELL YOU
ABOUT THIS PEOPLE WHO COULD NOT
OPEN UP A COMPUTER AT HOME. AND
WORK FROM HOME. THEY WERE THAT
THEY WERE THE FRONT LINE
WORKERS AT THE GROCERY STORE.
THERE WERE ARE HEALTH CARE
WORKERS. THERE WERE PEOPLE OF
FAST FOOD PEOPLE AT BANKS.
PEOPLE WHO KEPT CALIFORNIA
GOING THE REST OF US WERE
FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO BE ABLE TO
WORK FROM HOME. THIS BILL IS
ABOUT EQUITY AND FAIRNESS. FOR
THOSE WHO SACRIFICE THEIR LIVES
SO THAT WE CAN PUT FOOD ON THE
TABLE. I'M GONNA SAY THAT AGAIN
THIS IS ABOUT THOSE PEOPLE. IN
OUR COMMUNITIES- KEPT
CALIFORNIA GOING. AND PUT THEIR
LIVES AT RISK. IT'S THE RIGHT
THING TO DO AND IT'S THE HUMANE
THING TO DO WE SPENT A LOT OF
TIME LAST YEAR. TALKING ABOUT
EQUITY. WE SPENT A LOT OF TIME.
FIGHTING FOR EQUITY. THIS IS
OUR OPPORTUNITY TO BRING SOME
OF THAT EQUITY HOME. BECAUSE
FRONT LINE WORKERS LITERALLY
ARE PUTTING THEIR JOBS ON THE
LINE. AND WHAT'S MORE SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE EXEMPTED. SO
THAT ARGUMENT. FOR MOST OF US
WERE CONCERNED ABOUT IMPACT OUR
MOMS BUT A MOM AND POP
BUSINESSES NO LONGER THERE.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT MULTI
MILLION DOLLAR BUSINESSES HERE.
AND WHAT'S MORE IS THAT COULD
BE REIMBURSED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. NOW WE SEE THE
NUMBERS ARE DECLINING ABETTING
AND QUANTIFIERS THAT'S A GOOD
THING. BUT WHERE THERE'S VALUES
THERE'S PEAKS AND THE PEAKS ARE
IN THOSE NEIGHBORHOODS. WHERE
FOLKS HAVE TO CONTINUE TO WORK.
I ASK EACH ONE OF OUR
COLLEAGUES TO TAKE A VOTE. VOTE
YES. FOR THOSE COMMUNITIES
THOSE PEOPLE IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD. WHO ARE JANITORS
WHO CLEAN OUR HOMES. WILL GIVE
US FAST FOOD OR GROCERY WORKERS
THE BUS DRIVERS HEALTH CARE
WORKERS. AND EVERYBODY ELSE
WHO'S PUT THEIR LIFE ON THE
LINE. IT'S NOT TOO MUCH TO
EXAGGERATE THE SAY THE PEOPLE
COULD DIE WHEN THEY GO TO WORK
BECAUSE THE EXACTLY WHAT COULD
HAPPEN. SOME PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA WERE. WERE FORTUNATE
ENOUGH TO WORK FROM HOME. OUR
FRONT LINE WORKERS WERE NOT AND
WE'RE JUST ASKING. TO BRING
EQUITY HOME ON THIS AND ALLOW
THEM. TO BE HOME WHEN COLBERT
HITS. THEIR HOUSEHOLD. I WOULD
THAT I ASK YOU FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MR SANTIAGO MISTER
WARD YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT AND SB NINETY
FIVE ENCOURAGE EVERYBODY TO
CONSIDER GIVING IT THEIR
SUPPORT HERE TODAY AND WHILE
MANY OF THE CONCERNS THAT WE
HAD OVER THE LAST YEAR AND HOW
THE IMPACTS OF. OFFERING PAID
SICK LEAVE MIGHT IMPACT
BUSINESS AS WE KNOW FROM
COUNTRIES THAT HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO DO THE RIGHT THING WHO HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO SUPPORT ALL OF
THEIR WORKERS WHO HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO SUPPORT THE PAYROLL WHO
HAVE BEEN ASKING PEOPLE TO STAY
HOME TO AVOID. THE SPREAD OF
CORONAVIRUS HAVE RESULTED IN
NET POSITIVE ECONOMIC INTO
THEIR COUNTRIES A NET POSITIVE
HEALTH IMPACTS TO THEIR
CITIZENRY AND WE SHOULD BE
SUPPORTING MEASURES LIKE THIS
FOR MUCH OF THE SAME REASONS
BECAUSE THE LAST THING THAT WE
WANT AT THIS ELEVENTH HOUR IS
THE FOURTH SURGE WE SHOULD BE
DOING EVERYTHING THIS IS FOUND
MONEY THIS IS MONEY NOW
THANKFULLY COMING TO US. FROM
THE LATEST AMULETS THAT WE CAN
PUT RIGHT BACK OUT INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE SHOULD BE DOING THESE KINDS
OF RIGHT THINGS THAT WE SHOULD
HAVE BEEN DOING ALL ALONG EVERY
TIME WE FOUND A NICKEL EVERY
TIME WE FOUND A RESOURCE TO BE
ABLE TO PUT IT OUT THERE AND
HELP THE WORKERS. SO THAT THEY
WOULDN'T HAVE TO MAKE THAT
CHOICE BETWEEN WHETHER OR NOT
THEY WERE GOING TO ENDANGER
THEMSELVES THEIR FAMILY THEIR
NEIGHBORS THEIR LOVED ONES
THEIR COWORKERS THE REST OF THE
COMMUNITY THIS IS A COMMON
SENSE A NO BRAINER OPPORTUNITY
TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT AND DO
THE RIGHT THING TO GET US OVER
THE LAST. COUPLE OF MONTHS THAT
WE HAVE AHEAD AND MAKE SURE
THAT IN ANYWHERE IN OUR
RESPECTIVE COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT OUR DISTRICTS THAT
WE DON'T HAVE ADDITIONAL
COMMUNITY OUTBREAKS THIS BILL
ALSO ALLOWS WORKERS WHO MIGHT
BE SUFFERING SOME OF THE
EFFECTS OR HAVE A DAY OR TWO OF
THE EFFECTS FROM GETTING A
VACCINE. TO BE ABLE TO USE PAID
SICK LEAVE WE WANT PEOPLE WE
KNOW THAT THE MESSAGES OUT
THERE THAT SOME PEOPLE ARE
GONNA HAVE THE SAME REACTION AS
MANY HUMAN BEINGS DUE TO
GETTING THE VACCINE BUT WE WANT
THEM TO GET VACCINATED THIS
SHOULD NOT HAVE TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN ANY OF THESE HEALTHCARE
NEEDS. AND THE ABILITY TO HAVE
A PAYCHECK SO I ASK YOU WHERE
EVER YOU HAVE BEEN ON THE
SPECTRUM. THE COURSE OF THE
LAST YEAR. AND THE
CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN THE
ECONOMY AND THE RIGHT OF
HEALTH. THE HEALTHY A
COMMUNITY. TO BE ABLE TO DO THE
RIGHT THING TO EMPLOY THIS
MONEY RIGHT BACK ON TO OUR
COMMUNITY TO PAY THE WORKERS-
THE SICKLY THAT THEY ARE DUE.
TO HELP SUPPORT OUR COMMUNITY
SO WE DO NOT HAVE ANOTHER
OUTBREAK. AND MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE TRANSITIONING ON ALL OF OUR
DISTRICTS. INTO SPACES THAT ARE
HEALTHY THAT ARE ECONOMICALLY
VIBRANT- AND THAT ARE
SUPPORTING THE FAMILIES OF THE
WORKERS. WITH THE INCOME THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO NEED TO BE
ABLE TO GET THROUGH THESE NEXT
COUPLE OF MONTHS I ASK FOR YOUR
STRONG AYE VOTE ON SB NINETY
FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER. MISTER BENNETT YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
WE'VE WE ARE HEARING THIS
AFTERNOON MANY COMPELLING
REASONS TO SUPPORT THIS BILL. I
WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
TRY TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF
CONFIDENCE IN GOVERNMENT. AND
THE CHALLENGE THAT WE HAVE
EXPERIENCED THOSE OF US THAT
ARE IN GOVERNMENT TRYING TO
KEEP PEOPLE'S CONFIDENCE IN
GOVERNMENT AND GROW PEOPLE'S
CONFIDENCE IN GOVERNMENT. SO WE
HAVE A CHALLENGE IN FRONT OF US
WE HAVE AN EXPIRY DEADLINE AND
WE NEEDED TO TAKE ACTION. AND I
HAVE BEEN VERY IMPRESSED AS A
NEW MEMBER OF THIS LEGISLATURE
TO COME HERE. AND WATCH THE
ASSEMBLY. STRUGGLE WITH ALL OF
THE COMPLICATING ISSUES THAT
ARE INVOLVED IN HOW DO YOU DO
THIS WHAT THE RULES WILL BE.
WHETHER BUSINESSES WILL BE
REIMBURSED WHICH BUSINESSES
SHOULD BE REIMBURSED IS THAT
COMING FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WHAT'S THE TIMING.
AND WEEK AFTER WEEK THIS BILL
MODIFIED AND SOME PEOPLE TALK
ABOUT LEGISLATION BEING LOOKING
LIKE SAUSAGE COMING TOGETHER
BUT I WOULD OFFER TO USE THIS
AS AN EXAMPLE OF THE
LEGISLATURE COMING TOGETHER
WITH THE BILL THAT DOES ONE
ESSENTIAL THING. AND THAT IS
FOR THOSE PEOPLE WHO REALLY
WANT TO MAKE A GOOD FAITH
EFFORT. TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
TAKE CARE OF BOTH THE EMPLOYEES
OF A BUSINESS THAT MAY HAVE
COVERED MAY BE EXPOSED TO
COVERT. AND THE EMPLOYERS WHO
ARE STRUGGLING WITH ALL OF THE
ADJUSTMENTS THEY'VE HAD TO GO
THROUGH FOR THE LAST YEAR AND
NOW HAVE. AN EXTENSION OF A OF
THE DEADLINE LIKE THIS WE HAVE
COME TOGETHER I'M NOT IN THE
AUTHORS OF THIS BILL OF COME
TOGETHER. WITH SOMETHING THAT
REINFORCES THOSE PEOPLE WHO
OPERATE WITH GOOD FAITH. IT
PROTECTS PEOPLE IF THEY MAKE A
GOOD FACE AIR. THEY DON'T HAVE
A LAWSUIT THROWN ADAM RIGHT
AWAY THEY HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO FIX THAT THIS IS GOING TO
STOP THOSE PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THEIR THE
LEVERAGE IN THE PRESSURE THEY
MAY HAVE ON THEIR EMPLOYEES.
WITHOUT BEING PUNITIVE AND SO
IT'S NOT THERE YOU NEVER CAN
WRITE A BILL THAT EVERYBODY
LIKES OR THAT YOU CAN DEFINE AS
PERFECT BUT TODAY I THINK WE
HAVE A GREAT BILL THAT
REINFORCES GOOD FAITH BEHAVIOR
AND ALSO DEMONSTRATES THAT. THE
LEGISLATURE CAN COME TOGETHER
AND WORK AS THE KINKS IN THE
PROBLEMS THE BILL SO I SUPPORT
A IVOTA THIS THING YOU VERY
MUCH MANAGE. THANK YOU MISTER
BENNETT THIS RECIPE YOU ARE A-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'VE IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINETY FIVE. I
AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN DIEGO EARLIER MADE THE
COMMENT THAT. WE SHOULD BE
PAYING. OUR WORKERS TO BE ABLE
TO STAY AT HOME DURING A
PANDEMIC. WE SHOULD BE PAYING
THEM TO STAY AT HOME TO
ENCOURAGE THEM TO GET VACCINES.
I DO WANT TO SAY HOWEVER THAT
THE- I BELIEVE IT SHOULD BE
GOVERNMENT BEST SHOULD BE
PAYING TO KEEP THE TO
INCENTIVIZE THE WORKERS TO STAY
AT HOME AND NOT THE SMALL
BUSINESSES. THAT IS WHY I
EXPRESSED EARLY CONCERNS ABOUT
THE POTENTIAL IMPACT OF THIS
BILL ON SMALL BUSINESSES YOU
KNOW I DO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT.
THAT THE- PROJECTIONS ARE
SHOWING THAT MAYBE UP 240% OF
ALL SMALL BUSINESSES MAY NOT
SURVIVE THIS PANDEMIC. AND LET
ME REMIND MY COLLEAGUES MY
ESPECIALLY MY DEMOCRATIC
COLLEAGUES THAT ONE SMALL
BUSINESSES GO UNDER THOSE JOBS
ARE GONE. A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
TALKING ABOUT YOU KNOW THE VERY
REAL CONCERN ABOUT WHETHER
THESE JOBS ARE GOING TO BE
COMING BACK. AND SO WHEN WE
WANT TO TALK ABOUT. YOU KNOW
DOING THE RIGHT THING FOR THE
WORKERS IN OUR COMMUNITIES WE
HAVE TO THINK ABOUT WHETHER
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE A JOB TO
COME BACK TO. SO YOU KNOW. I
AGREE WITH MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES THAT THIS IS. A
COMPROMISE IT'S A COMPROMISE.
GIVEN THE EXTRAORDINARY TIMES
OF THIS PANDEMIC. WE DO WANT TO
PAY WORKERS WE DO WANT
INCENTIVIZE WORKERS. TO STAY AT
HOME DURING A PANDEMIC AND THAT
IS THE REASON WHY I'M
SUPPORTING THIS. ESPECIALLY
APPRECIATE. THE EXEMPTION FOR
THE SMALLEST OF THE SMALL
BUSINESSES. THOSE WITH TWENTY
FIVE EMPLOYEES OR FEWER. AND SO
I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL. THANK YOU MISTER COULD
YOU MISTER MATTHEWS YOU ARE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS.
I RISE BECAUSE- MY B. S. METERS
FULL WHEN IT COMES TO THE
COMMENTS I'VE HEARD ON THIS
BILL. YOU KNOW THE FIRST
MILLENNIAL COMBAT VETERAN WITH
A PURPLE HEART ELECTED TO STATE
OFFICE IN THE COUNTRY. I FIND
IT EXTREMELY APPALLING. TO
LISTEN TO SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES
SPEAK ABOUT LIFE OR DEATH. THE
WAY I'VE HEARD. YEAH THIS BILLS
GOT A CARVE OUT FOR TWENTY FIVE
EMPLOYEES OR LESS. LET'S LET'S
TYPICAL POLICY WE SEE THIS
LET'S PUT A CAP AT TWENTY FIVE
SO YOU KNOW. THE COMPANY THAT'S
GOT TWENTY SIX EMPLOYEES IS
TOTALLY SCREWED. LET'S TALK
ABOUT THE FACT THAT. WE'VE SEEN
SUICIDE RATES RISE BY OVER
4100% 104% MEMBERS. I COME FROM
A PLACE WHERE MY BROTHERS AND
SISTERS ARE COMBAT VETERANS
TWENTY TWO DIE SUICIDE A DAY.
AND I'M SEEING THAT AFFECT OUR
BUSINESS COMMUNITY ARE WORKERS
EVERYBODY. A 4100% RICE. DON'T
TALK TO ME ABOUT A LIFE OR
DEATH. THE STOCK ABOUT THE FACT
THAT THIS BILL IS RETRO ACTIVE.
SO LET'S BREAK DOWN WHAT THAT
MEANS FOR SOME O YOU WHO
APPARENTLY DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHAT THAT MEANS. IT MEANS THAT
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK. IN
BUSINESSES THAT HAVE ALREADY
HAD TO DEAL WITH THIS THE
DIDN'T KNOW THIS THAT WE'RE NOT
PLANNING ON THIS. THIRD JUST
OVER THE BRINK. ARE GOING TO
GET KICKED. WITH THE LAWSUIT.
BUT MAYBE ALREADY KNEW THAT
MAYBE YOUR ATTORNEY BUDDIES
BACK HOME ARE ALREADY PLANNING
THOSE LAWSUIT TELL MAYBE
THEY'RE ALREADY WRITTEN OUT. WE
FIND IT SURPRISING. SO WHAT'S
GONNA HAPPEN WHEN THAT LAWSUIT
HAPPENS LET'S TALK ABOUT THAT
SINCE YOU'RE SO WORRIED ABOUT
LIFE AND DEATH. WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN IS THAT BUSINESS THAT'S
GOT. TWENTY SIX EMPLOYEES. IT'S
GONNA FILE BANKRUPTCY. IN THOSE
TWENTY SIX PEOPLE THEY'RE
COMING OUT OF A JOB. NOBODY
ELSE IS HIRING BECAUSE IT'S
STILL COVERED WE'RE STILL GOING
THROUGH THIS THERE'S NO WAY FOR
ME TO GO THE OTHER SMALL
BUSINESSES. ARE GOING THROUGH
THE SAME THING. YOU'LL THE GO
4100% SUICIDE RATE IS A JOKE.
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN WHEN IT
RETROACTIVELY CLONES IN HITS
THESE PEOPLE BECAUSE THEY'RE
ABOVE THAT TWENTY FIVE. THEY'RE
GOING DOWN TAT'S LIFE OR DEATH.
THAT'S THE REALITY. THIS
DOESN'T HELP THEM IT KILLS THEM
ASK FOR NOBLE ON SB NINETY
FIVE. THANK YOU MR MCAFEE.
TORONTO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINETY FIVE AND
SINCE THERE'S BEEN SOME DEBATE
ON THIS I WANT TO TOUCH ON THE
RETROACTIVE COMPONENT OF THE
BILL AND ITS RELATIONSHIP TO
THE PRIVATE ATTORNEYS GENERAL
ACT OR PAGA WHICH WAS
REFERENCED EARLIER COMMENTS IN
HERE'S HOW THE BILL WILL WORK
ITS ALL SET FORTH VERY CLEARLY
IN THE BILL AN EMPLOYER CANNOT
BE IN VIOLATION OF PAGA. UNLESS
THEY ARE IN VIOLATION OF A
STATUTORY OBLIGATION IN THIS
CASE THE STATUTORY OBLIGATION
DOES NOT TAKE EFFECT UNTIL JAN
TEN DAYS AFTER THE BILL'S%
ENACTMENT TEN DAYS AFTER THE
BILL'S ENACTMENT THE BILL CALLS
FOR A RETROACTIVE PAYMENT FROM
THE EMPLOYER AFTER THE WORKER
REQUESTED AND AB EIGHTY FOUR SB
NINETY FIVE ALLOWS FOR THE REST
ABOUT THE PAYMENT TO BE PAID ON
OR BEFORE. THE NEXT PAYDAY THIS
HELPS ENSURE EMPLOYERS CAN MAKE
THE PAYMENT AS PART OF THE
TYPICAL PAY CYCLE ALREADY
PROGRAMMED INTO THEIR BUSINESS
OPERATIONS ADDITIONALLY THE
BILL CLARIFIES HOW THE RATE OF
PAY IS CALCULATED WHICH ALSO
HELPS ENSURE EMPLOYERS ARE NOT
UNFAIRLY PENALIZED SO THE BILL
IS VERY SPECIFIC ON HOW
PAYMENTS ARE TO BE REQUESTED.
AND HOW THEY ARE TO BE MADE SO
TO BE CLEAR AN EMPLOYER WILL
NOT HAVE VIOLATED ANY STATUTORY
OBLIGATION TRIGGERING POTENTIAL
PAGA PENALTIES UNTIL AFTER
AFTER THE LEGISLATION TAKES
EFFECT I REQUEST FOR
RETROACTIVE PAYMENT IS MADE AND
IF THE EMPLOYER FAILS TO MAKE
THE RETROACTIVE PAYMENT BY THE
APPLICABLE DUE DATE OTHERWISE
THE EMPLOYER WILL NOT HAVE
VIOLATED ANY STATUTORY
OBLIGATION SO THERE WILL BE NO
VIOLATION OF THE LABOR CODE.
TRIGGERING AN EMPLOYER'S RIGHT
EMPLOYEES LIKE THE POPULARLY IF
AN EMPLOYER FOLLOWS THE CLEAR
PROVISIONS IN THE BILL THEY
WILL NOT AND CANNOT BE
PENALIZED HOPE THAT CLARIFIES
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES. I URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK
YOU MISS BONTA.
MISTER SPEAKER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO ASK YOUR
SUPPORT FOR SB NINETY FIVE I'VE
SEEN THE ASSEMBLY DO A LOT OF
IMPORTANT WORK- IN MY YEARS AS
SPEAKER ONE OF THE THINGS I'M
MOST PROUD OF IS HOW WE HAVE
RISEN TO THE CHALLENGES OF THE
COVE A PANDEMIC. WHEN FIRST
WHEN WE FIRST CONFRONTED THIS
CHALLENGE A YEAR AGO WE QUICKLY
WORKED TOGETHER IN A BIPARTISAN
FASHION TO PROVIDE FUNDING TO
TRY TO PROTECT CALIFORNIANS
TODAY IS ANOTHER TIME WE HAVE
TO ACT QUICKLY AND DECISIVELY
TO PROTECT CALIFORNIANS I'M
GRATEFUL FOR THE HARD WORK OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WENDY CARILLO
AND ARANDA GONZALEZ FOR HELPING
TO BRING THIS BILL TO A POINT
WHERE WE CAN TAKE ACTION TO DO
JUST THAT. IT TAKES NO GREAT
FEAT OF IMAGINATION TO SEE THE
HARDSHIPS OF WORKERS WHO FEEL
COVE AND FORCING THEM. TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN HEALTH AND A
PAYCHECK. THEY SHOULD NOT HAVE
TO MAKE THAT CHOICE. EMERGENCY
HOUSE WE'VE SHOULD BE THERE
RIGHT THIS IS OUR OPPORTUNITY
TO PROVIDE IT. THIS BILL IS
STRUCTURED TO EXEMPT SMALL
BUSINESSES WITH FEWER THAN
TWENTY FIVE EMPLOYEES. THAT IS
pECONOMIC BACKBONE. BUT THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING WE CAN DO FOR
WORKPLACES IS TO MAKE SURE
WORKERS ARE HEALTHY. THAT IS
ALSO THE BEST THING WE CAN DO
FOR CALIFORNIA. WE CAN DO THAT
TODAY I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
ON SB NINETY FIVE. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. MEMBER CENTER
ACTION WE'RE TEMPORARY
TEMPORARILY PASSING ON THIS
ITEM AND WILL MOVE BACK TO IT
AT A LATER TIME. IN THE ADDRESS
THE PROTECTION WE WILL NOW TAKE
UP OUR TOURNAMENT IN MEMORY
TODAY THE FOLLOWING MEMBER WAS
GRANTED PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON
ANY GERMAN IN MEMORY. MR FONG
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. I THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER. MEMBERS TODAY I
RISE TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY
OF JACK THOMPSON WHO PASSED
AWAY AT THE AGE OF NINETY EIGHT.
JACK WAS BORN OIL CENTER JUST
OUTSIDE OF BAKERSFIELD IN
NINETEEN TWENTY TWO. AND HE
GREW UP HELPING ON HIS
GRANDFATHER'S FARM IN NEARBY
BUT WHILE STAYING TRUE TO ITS
CALIFORNIA ROOTS JACKET TO THE
BASE OF COLLEGE AND THEN
ATTENDED UC DAVIS BEFORE
SERVING IN THE U. S. NAVY. AS A
PILOT IN THE PACIFIC THEATER
DOING WORLD TWO. FOLLOWING
MILITARY SERVICE RIGHT. HE
RETURNED TO CAN. TO THE GREAT
STAY. LOW HE'S AS A SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBER A BOARD MEMBER OF
CHURCH ELECT LOCAL CIVIL
SERVICE. AND ON ACCOUNT OF
WATER COMMISSION. BUT HE DID
STOP THERE. JACK WAS A FOUNDING
MEMBER OF THE KERN COUNTY WATER
AGENCY SERVED AS PRESIDENT OF
THE KERN COUNTY FARM BUREAU HE
WAS EVEN INSTRUMENTAL IN
ESTABLISHING THE STATE WATER
PROJECT WHICH NOW DISTRIBUTES
WATER. ALL ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
JACK WAS EVEN PIVOTAL IN THE
NEGOTIATIONS TO CONSTRUCT THE
FEATHER RATHER THE FEATHER
RIVER DAM WHICH NOW OFFERS ONE
OF THE PRIMARY SOURCES. OF KERN
COUNTY'S IRRIGATION WATER. HE
WAS A VETERAN. A FARMER. AND A
PIONEER IN BRINGING WATER TO
THE CENTER VALLEY HE WAS A
BELOVED FATHER. GRANDFATHER AND
GREAT GRANDFATHER. ALL NOT ALL
OF US MAY NOT HAVE KNOWN JACK
WE ARE ALL ALL IMPACTED BY HIS
LEGACY. WE CELEBRATE THE
AMAZING LIFE YOU LIVED IN THE
TREMENDOUS LEGACY OF SERVICE HE
LEFT FOR US WE HONOR HIS
COMMITMENT TO OUR COMMUNITY.
OUR STATE AND OUR NATION I ASK
THAT THE ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED IN
HIS MEMORY TODAY. THANK YOU MR
FONG PLEASE BRING THE NAMES THE
DEATH TO BE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL ALL REQUESTED YOUR TO
MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
THIS
PRESS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULES. SEVENTY SEVEN
M. SIXTY THREE. TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAM TO TAKE UP
AB. EIGHTY THREE BUDGET
COMMITTEE TODAY. WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE FOR
CONCURRENCE IN SENATE
AMENDMENTS WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER. MADAM
SPEAKER I ALSO ASK I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE SEVENTY SEVEN
SIXTY THREE TO ALLOW SOMEONE
NUMBER TEN TO TAKE UP. AB
EIGHTY EIGHT. BUDGET COMMITTEE
TODAY WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE
FOR CONCURRENCE IN SENATE
AMENDMENTS WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER. WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO AB EIGHTY
THREE WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE
THE CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHTY THREE BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AN ACCOLADE
THE BUSINESS OF PROFESSIONS
MAKING APPROPRIATION OF FORTY
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. THIRTEEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED UP IN A MATTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH PRESENTING
AB EIGHTY THREE THIS BILL
CLARIFIES SOME OF THE- SMALL
ISSUES THAT WE HAD WITH THE
PREVIOUS BUDGET BILL FOR THE
FOR THE SMALL BUSINESS PEOPLE%
LEAVE CLEAN UP. GLORIFIED THE
FROM SMALL BREWERIES WINERIES
AND CRAFT DISTILLERIES ARE
EXEMPT FROM THE ALCOHOL AND
BEVERAGE CONTROL FEES. THE BILL
ALSO INCLUDES THREE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR FROM THE GENERAL
FUND TO OFFSET THE EXPECTED
LOSS OF FEE. REVENUE FROM THIS
CHANGE WITHOUT A RESPECT FOR US
FOR ABOUT. THANK YOU MISTER
SINISTER FONG YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. BUT THINK ABOUT
SPEAKER I MEMBERS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTY THREE I'M
CERTAIN WE HAVE ALL HEARD FROM
OUR LOCAL WINERIES BREWERIES
AND DISTILLERS AND ARE
COMMUNITIES THAT TEETERED ON
THE EDGE ARE GOING OUT OF
BUSINESS. OVER THIS PAST YEAR.
IS VERY ENCOURAGING TO SEE THIS
BODY RECOGNIZE THE STRIFE OF
SOME OF OUR SMALL BUSINESSES
AND OFFER INCREMENTAL STEPS TO
KEEP THEM AFLOAT. I URGE AN AYE
VOTE ON AB EIGHTY THREE. THANK
YOU MR FONG SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE
MATTER. MISTER KING WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. CLERK WILL OPEN
THE- VERY VOTE ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ON
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. WHERE ALL MEMBERS THOSE
WHO THEIR VOTE. WHERE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. LIVING A FILE ITEM EIGHTY
EIGHT WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE
FOR AB EIGHTY EIGHT WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE THE CLERK
WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTY
EIGHT BY THE COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AND THAT POLITICAL THE
NINETEEN RELIEF MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. THINKING YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THE MATTER
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER THIS IS
FURTHER CLEAN UP FROM THE
GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS ACT THAT
WE PASSED A FEW WEEKS AGO. THE
BILL EXEMPTS THE GOLDEN STATE
STIMULUS PAYMENTS OFTHE GOLDEN
STATE GRANT PAYMENTS FROM
GARNISHMENT ORDERS EXCEPT FOR.
SPELLS FOR EXCEPT FOR SPOUSAL
SUPPORT CHILD SUPPORT FAMILY
SUPPORT FOR CRIMINAL
RESTITUTION PAYABLE TO VICTIMS'
THE BAT ALSO EXCLUDES GOLDEN
STATE GRANT PAYMENTS FROM GROSS
INCOME SIMILAR. TO EXISTING LAW
FOR THE GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS
PAYMENTS. A. B. A. B. A. ALSO
CLARIFIES VARIOUS DEFINITIONS
INCLUDING THAT OF A QUALIFIED
RECIPIENT TO SHORTEN THE VIGIL
WHO CAN BE CLAIMED AS A
DEPENDENT IS NOT INCLUDED. WITH
THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU MISS KING MR FONG ARE
ON THE MATTER. I THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBER THAT RISES.
OF AB EIGHTY EIGHT. THIS BILL
MAKE SURE THE RELIEF PROVIDED
IN THE GOLDEN STATE SAYING THIS
PROGRAM. WILL NOT BE TAXED
UNFAIRLY TAKEN BACK FROM THE
POCKETS A VERY VERY VERY THE
VERY CALIFORNIANS WERE TRYING
TO HELP. DEFIES ALL COMMON
SENSE TO CALL BACK THE VERY
LIFE PLANS THAT WE EXTENDED TO
BUSINESS OWNERS TO KEEP THEM
AFLOAT. WITH WHY WE NEED TO
PASS THIS BILL I ORIGINAL VOTE
ON AB EIGHTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
MR FONG SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
VERY VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED A VERITABLE. WHERE WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN.
MEMBERS. MISTER SEA ARE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
ANNOUNCEMENT. THANK YOU ARE
MEMBERS I WOULD BE REMISS IF I
DID NOT RECOGNIZE ANOTHER WOMAN
HERE IN THEIR HOUSES BEEN
BREAKING GLASS CEILINGS AND
THAT'S OUR CHIEF SERGEANT LISA
BUCKLEY- AND I ALSO WANT TO
RECOGNIZE OUR FIVE
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICERS MANY
LESSER WITH THIS YEAR IN THE
LEGISLATURE. AS WELL OUT THERE
WE HAVE OUR SECRETARY OF STATE
SHIRLEY WEBER WHO JUST RECENTLY
LEFT US WE HAVE OUR TREASURER
FIONA MAMA OUR CONTROLLER
BETTY. OUR LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
LED COULD UNLOCK HIS AND
WILLIAM COHEN WHO'S WITH THE
BOARD OF EQUALIZATION AND SO I
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE RECOGNIZE
THESE GREAT WOMEN WHO'VE ALSO
BEEN BREAKING BARRIERS AND
BEETLE MODELS FOR US ALL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MR GARCIA.
MEMBERS. MISTER SEA ARE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR ANOTHER
ANNOUNCEMENT YES AND THANK YOU
IT'S EXCITED THAT WE'RE
CELEBRATING WOMEN'S HISTORY
MONTH AND ALL THE WOMEN
BREAKING GLASS CEILINGS AND
JUST RIGHT NOW THAT HOLLAND IS
CONFIRMED AS BIDEN'S INTERIOR
SECRETARY AS STARK MOVE MAKING
HER THE FIRST DAY OF AMERICAN
CABINET SECRETARY- ITH THE
VOTED FIFTY ONE TO FORTY AND SO
WANTED TO RECOGNIZE THAT
HISTORIC VOTE- THAT JUST
HAPPENED RIGHT NOW HOVOR
CELEBRATING WOMEN'S HISTORY
MONTH. MY COLLEAGUE HERE IS
GOING TO STEP INTO. THAT'S WHAT
IT THANK OF THIS ASSEMBLY ON
THE SPEAKER FOR WRITING
LETTERS- FOR THE CONFIRMATION
OF DEB HAALAND. THE FIRST
NATIVE AMERICAN WOMAN AND THE
FIRST NATIVE AMERICAN TO BECOME
SECRETARY OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
THE INTERIOR IN THE UNITED
STATES HISTORY. LET'S GIVE
A ROUND OF APPLAUSE RIGHT THERE.
YES SHE WAS CONFIRMED ON A
FIFTY ONE TO FORTY VOTE WHICH
SHOWS WE STILL HAVE A LOT OF
WORK TO DO IN BUILDING
EDUCATION AND MAKING SURE THE
PEOPLE IN THE NATIVE AMERICAN
COMMUNITY CONTINUE TO STRIVE TO
MOVE FORWARD TO GET. INTO A
LECTERN OFFICES CONGRATULATIONS
THE DEVIL HOLON BECOMING THE
FIRST SECRETARY OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF THE INTERIOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR ON A
CEMEX GARCIA IT IS AN
INCREDIBLE DAY. TO HAVE THEM
CALL AND CONFIRMED THEIR FIRST
NEW AMERICAN SECRETARY OF THE
INTERIOR IT IS FAR PAST TIME.
MEMBERS WE ASK YOU TO RETURN TO
THE FLOOR FOR THE FINAL VOTE
TODAY. WHO.
MEMBERS WE WILL
TURN BACK TO SENATE BILL NINETY
FIVE I WILL REMIND YOU MEMBERS
THAT THE BILL HAD BEEN READ BY
THE READING PARK DEBATE HAS
BEEN CONCLUDED AND MISTER KING
HAS WAIVED HIS CLOTHES SO THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE AND IT.
ALL MEMBERS OF. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THIRTY TO
THEIR TO VOTE. YEAH. BURKE WELL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE IS FIFTY THREE KNOWS
NINETEEN THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS MEMBERS
PLEASE BE SURE TO PICK UP MY
TOLD BAG FROM THE ASSEMBLY
SERGEANTS AT THE RULES
COMMITTEE HEARING ROOM ON YOUR
WAY OUT. THESE GO BACK THERE
COURTESY OF THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS.
THIS SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS TUESDAY MARCH SIXTEENTH
WE CHECK IN SESSION WEDNESDAY
MARCH SEVENTEENTH CHECK IN
SESSION THURSDAY MARCH
EIGHTEENTH WORK SESSION AT NINE
AM. ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING
WILL BE PASSED RETAINED ALL
MOTIONS SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN THIS RACE
MOVES AND MISS WALDRON SECONDS
AT THE HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL THURSDAY. MARCH
EIGHTEENTH AT NINE AM.
WORMHOLES LIFTED.